que se passe-t-il au bureau du premier
ministre québécois sous pression et yann
plante un nouvel employé du cabinet a
démissionné après 38 jours avant ça il
était employé à la coalition avenir
québec est la veille de son départ il
s'est transférée par courrier à des
documents confidentiels
ordre du jour est un financier stratégie
électorale selon l'acq acq la cac
l'accusé cette semaine de vol et a même
déposé deux mises en demeure contre lui
et une autre contre le chef de cabinet
de philippe couillard jean louis
dufresne
pas plus tard qu'hier philippe couillard
défendeurs son nouvel employé c'est un
spectacle de diversion monsieur leubou
faire de toute façon au précieux même
pot que goût document stratégique web un
bel intérêt dans sa lettre de démission
et yann plantes parle de mensonge
pourtant selon nos informations dans une
autre lettre du 9 septembre
il a admis avoir détruit des documents
l'entourage premier ministre doit être
intègre et à ce moment si on se pose de
sérieuses questions
disons que ça ne va pas bien pour les
transfuges qui est la ministre dominique
anglade prévoyaient embaucher un ancien
recherchiste de la cac
frédéric chau tôt mais lui aussi ils
avaient subtilisé des documents le
gouvernement couillard avait minimisé la
faire pour finalement se raviser
encore une fois